bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ça vous regarde en version d confiné
c'est parti voici le sommaire qu'il
était bon ce petit café ce matin en
terrasse les français renouer avec les
plaisirs du quotidien comment ont-ils
vécu ce premier jour du reste de nos
vies et est-ce le signe du retour des
jours heureux comme le dit emmanuel
macron le coc vide
enfin il nous changer nous faire prendre
de nouvelles habitudes au quotidien on
fera le bilan de cette nouvelle étape du
déconfinement dans un instant nous
reviendrons aussi sur l'amérique
l'amérique qui étale ses déchirures aux
dieux du monde c'est sans doute l'une
des crises les plus graves depuis
l'élection de donald trump la mort de
georges floyd cet afro-américain d'une
quarantaine d'années asphyxié par un
policier blanc a fait exploser la colère
dans tout le pays face aux protestations
trump choisi la force
jusqu'où ira lincendie la campagne
présidentielle se jouera-t-elle sur la
question raciale
nous en débattrons avec nos invités
enfin le jour d'après nouvel épisode de
notre série d'entretiens thématique ce
soit la chef économiste de l'eau cdo
laurence boone analyse les différents
scénarios de la reprise possible à
l'heure où la récession phase de 8 à 11%
du pib cette année voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti #fb r ça vous
savez ça n'a pas changé son livre
[Musique]
on
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
même les députés ses dires ne boudaient
pas leur plaisir ce matin à la terrasse
élargie du bourbon face à l'assemblée
c'est renouer un petit peu avec l'avant
crise c'est retrouver des habitudes
j'avais envie avant d'aller à même à mon
bureau de boire ce qu'a fait sur cette
place voilà c'est ce que je fais ce qui
m'a manqué c'est l'improvisation de
passer ici juste cinq minutes prendre un
café
ce qui m'a manqué c'est d'être sur cette
place et de pouvoir simplement prendre
le temps de réfléchir j'ai un livre avec
moi je suis très heureux aujourd'hui que
les terrasses puisse rouvrir
bonsoir frédéric saldmann soit vous avez
profiter de la terrasse
aujourd'hui encore mais ce soir oui je
dis café ou pas petit café non pas petit
caf
mais ce soir je vais dîner terrasse de
restaurant lo bonheur et on est ravi de
vous accueillir avant ce ses grandes
retrouvailles en terrasse et en amis
vous êtes médecin cardiologue les
français vous connaissent nutritionniste
aussi et auteur à succès au point que
cet ouvrage on n'est jamais mieux
soigner que par soi même aux éditions
plon a déjà franchi le seuil des cent
mille exemplaires on va parler avec vous
de toutes ses petites habitudes
nouvelles acquises pendant le
confinement qu'ovide oblige qui pourrait
perdurer après vous dialoguez ce soir
avec bruno fuchs bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député modem
du haut rhin département qui a payé un
lourd tribut à cause évidemment du duc
au vide toutes ces dernières semaines
vous me direz comment vos électeurs sur
place vive ce retour ou plus ou moins
retour à la normale difficilement d'un
mouton très attendue parce que en plus
du coc vide et du confinement que nous
avons tous connu mulhouse subi un
couvre-feu de 21h à 6h du matin pendant
plus d'un mois et demi et dont on vous
parlait il ya une volonté de nous
ressortir vraiment beaucoup plus forte
peut-être qu'ailleurs la lumière ou du
tunnel je vous donne la parole messieurs
dans un instant vous savez celui qui
ouvre l'émission c'est stéphane
blakowski qu'at-il compris à ce que nous
avons traversée si j'ai bien compris
c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane alors quel regard
portez-vous sur toute cette phase est
cette page qui se tourne avec ce
déconfinement ce quasi retour à la
normale aujourd'hui si j'ai bien compris
c'est le titre de la chronique justement
le coc vide est un virus qui rend très
difficile à comprendre important je vous
promets que c'est pas faute d'essayer
mais bon on a beau lire tous les
journaux toute la journée pour essayer
d'y voir plus clair
au bout du compte c'est très très
difficile de se faire un avis si on
prend par exemple la question qui
aujourd'hui paraît la plus préoccupante
c'est à dire
va-t-il y avoir une seconde vague
d'épidémie
bon bah moi il ya quinze jours je disais
un de mes magazines préférés le point et
j'ai pris un petit coup de flip une
inquiétude parce que voilà un article
qui nous disait l'europe connaîtra une
deuxième vague mais il s'était assez
catégorique et simplement cette semaine
en reprenant mon magazine préféré
qu'est ce que j'apprends que un
urgentiste de la salpêtrière dit
exactement le contraire puisqu'il
affirme que selon lui il n'y aura pas de
deuxième vague et quand on lit ce qu'on
interviewe à que professeur frank est
assez catégorique de ce point de vue bon
alors moi je voulais pas du tout en
cause le point ni un autre média le
problème c'est qu'il ya eu tellement
d'études scientifiques tous été publiés
pendant la crise par des laboratoires
par des spécialistes que tous ne disent
pas la même chose donc pour les médias
très compliqué de faire le tri entre ce
qui est du domaine de la certitude
et puisqu'il reste une hypothèse alors
parmi les questions qu'on se pose c'est
par exemple est-ce que le coc vide est
une épidémie saisonnière
bah on ne sait pas vraiment est ce que
le soleil la chaleur c'était battre la
coqueluche du russe
bah on n'est pas vraiment sûr est ce que
les enfants sont un des principaux
vecteurs de l'épidémie
bon alors ça je crois qu'on peut
répondre non pas non mais quand même un
petit peu voyez rien n'est jamais tout à
fait catégorique alors comment s'y
retrouver dans cette masse d'incertitude
très très difficile puisque même les
plus grands spécialistes de la question
en sont venus à se tromper
évidemment tout le monde a en tête de
notre star depuis le début de l'épidémie
le professeur raoul
voilà ce qu'ils disaient le 17 février
contre lui demandait est ce qu'un risque
d'épidémie monde épidémie mondiale mais
a très peu de maladies infectieuses qui
se répandent dans tout les espaces de la
terre
un moment ça n'existe pas on a
l'impression qu'on n'est plus dans un
jeu vidéo comme risque si vous voulez où
les gens appuie sur un bouton à chaque
fois qu'il ya un cas dans un pays même
si un milliard d'habitants et boussès et
rouge
ça y est le virus envahi la terre tout
ça c'est des bêtises alors évidemment ce
n'est pas parce que le professeur roux
s'est trompé une fois qu'il va se
tromper à chaque fois ce serait beaucoup
trop simple tout le monde a en tête
bien sûr la question qu'on s'est posée
pendant un mois la chloroquine est elle
efficace
on croyait avoir trouvé la solution
puisque dallas est un magazine de
référence a dit non mais pas du tout
c'est dangereux la chloroquine et puis
finalement cette étude d'un magazine
très sérieux a été étudiée très
sérieusement
il se trouve qu'il est bourré d'erreurs
et du coup au bout du compte on ne sait
toujours pas quoi vraiment en pensez
alors que faire face à tant
d'incertitudes
j'ai pas d'un côté on serait évidemment
tenté prendre un maximum de précautions
pour limiter les risques et en même
temps est ce qu'un excès de précaution
n'aura pas des conséquences encore plus
graves sur l'économie sociale voyez on
s'en sort pas
à force de à défaut en quelque sorte
d'avoir des certitudes à toutes les
questions qu'on se pose on peut en moins
en débattre avec moi d'ailleurs pour
intervenir dans ce débat même à distance
derrière votre écran
je vous attends très vite c'est
peut-être possible dans dans les
semaines à venir frédéric saldmann pour
rebondir sur le billet de stéphane c'est
vrai que on a l'impression qu'on est
entré au début de la crise avec une
incertitude absolue sur ce nouveau virus
qu'on découvrait et qu'on en sort un peu
de la même manière sans trop comprendre
pourquoi au fond il n'ya presque plus de
cas dans le pays
on nous disait qu'il ya encore deux
semaines une deuxième vague était
possible qu'elle circulait qui peut être
très prudent il faut l'être bien sûr
mais au fond néant dans un quasi retour
à la normale ce niveau d'incertitude là
au début comme à la fin vous comprenez
oui on apprend l'humilité en médecine
c'est à dire que en fait un nouveau
virus
on connaît pas bien la façon dont il va
se propager rappelez vous il ya trente
ans le sida eu plein pot tech on
cafouille est on cherche encore
d'ailleurs le vaccin qu'on n'a toujours
pas trouvé où on a mis vingt ans à
trouver un traitement mais vous êtes
surpris vous part au fond
ce moment où on sent bien qu'on peut
regarder d'ailleurs les graphiques la
courbe d admission en réanimation
s'effondrent c'était pas attendu sous ou
si c'est à dire qu'en fait on se réjouit
bien sûr de la réouverture il faut que
les pays reparte mais un temps quelle
surprise on a l'impression d'être un peu
dans le brouillard on serait joué avec
prudence regardez à singapour ça allait
très bien et puis à un moment donné
c'est reparti donc quelque part quand tu
auras plus du tout cas on passe à 0,10
c'est fini tant qu'il ya encore des
petits foyers des petits car on reste
très vigilent si c'est pas cezio n'y est
pas ce qu on voit quand même qu'il ya
des pays où il fait chaud il ya beaucoup
de cas c'est quoi alors il arrive et
repart elle en fait qu'à sa tête ce
virus dans ce n'est pas en fait du
nombre de sujets qui sont contaminés qui
vont contaminer d'autres vous allez dans
les virus ça se joue sur l'immunité plus
l'immunité costaud - en risque
l'immunité de la france est visée on en
est on avance on a l'impression qu'on
est pour figer la même à 50 la situation
plus on avance en âge plus de l'immunité
diminue pour ça qu'à 90 ans peut mourir
d'une simple grippe
donc en fait on a une limite et qui
diminue physiologiquement on n'a pas de
médicaments pour augmenter notre
immunité
par contre le mode de vie est
déterminant pour le fou le politique qui
regarde ça et qui est forcément écoute
les scientifiques au risque d'ailleurs
de se tromper parce qu'ils sont parfois
contradictoires
vous êtes surpris je rappelle qu'il faut
se réjouir de ce qui nous arrive c'est
une évidence puisque il y avait de moins
en moins de cas mais tout de même le
fait que vous ayez encore un professeur
stéphane en parlait d'urgentistes
johnatan freund par exemple à la pitié
salpêtrière qui dit ait plus un seul
quatre vit dans les services faute ou
rouvrir plus vite encore il y à la
connaissance que l'on a du virus il ya
la connaissance scientifique l approche
médicale le comportement des individus
jusqu'à la manifestation de l'église
évangélique à mulhouse de 2000 personnes
le virus était sous contrôle des gamins
cluster on arrivait à identifier donc on
arrivait à maîtriser en tout cas
l'évolution à la connaître elle a
maîtrisé il est programmé à partir du
moment où il ya eu extrêmement
évidemment mais normal ou de 2000
personnes pendant une semaine
hélas le virus est parti dans france
entière du des ehpad entier qui ont été
décimés dans ma dans ma circonscription
aux prêts à près de mulhouse parce que
justement il y avait des d'aidés
soignants des gens qui travaillent dans
les états qui ont participé fin et la
situation d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui c'est sourire sous contrôle
on est complètement je pense un avantage
sur d'autres régions c'est qu'on a un
taux de personnes qui ont été touchées
bien supérieur à la moyenne nationale
donc la propagation si elle devait
revenir dans une deuxième vague seraient
moindres à mon avis dans le haut rhin en
alsace et en moselle que dans le reste
de ses habitants venus en adressant oui
respire je le vois tous les jours sur
sur des vélos vers les gens veulent
sortir ils ont envie de respirer mais
ils ont tous je pense qu'on vivra la
préco vide puisque c'est votre
thématique de soi un peu différemment
dans les territoires quand il est très
touché parce qu'autour de nous nous
avons tous soit des personnes qui sont
décédées
moi j'ai trois élus proches de mes
communes qui sont décédés de de cette
maladie et il nous avons tous si c'est
pas le cas des gens qui ont été
gravement atteints
servier témoignages de gens indépendants
une semaine dix jours pouvait pas se
lever
j'ai l'impression qu'il avait mûri
qu'ils étaient dans l'incapacité de
faire le moindre jeu sera d'ailleurs
j'imagine les cérémonies oui lui ira ça
et quand vous avez vécu dans votre chair
moigne âge ce type de manifestation
physique
je pense que
après en tout cas dans les mois qui
suivent peut plus être le même beaucoup
de gens qui vont agir différemment
est-ce que collectivement après on
arrivera à changer de mode de vie aussi
vite je suis pas sûr mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui dans leur chair ou ont
intégré le fait qu' il voulait vivre
différemment il en approche un peu
différente avant après le comité alors
justement sur les bonnes habitudes qui
pourront peut-être rester dans l'après
coville professeur salzmann je pense au
lavage des mains je pense à tous ces
gestes barrières cette hygiène qu'on a à
l'est soit pour certains découvert
d'autres pour répété de nombreuses fois
par jour vous pensez que ça va rester il
faut que ça reste je le souhaite de tout
mon coeur
vous savez dans les années 60 on décide
d'arrêter l'enseignement de l'hygiène à
l'école dans les collèges les
universités partout des mamans aux
enfants parce qu'on dit c'est plus la
peine de s'arrêter il ya les
antibiotiques maintenant grosse erreur
parce que d'abord les antibiotiques sur
les virus ça n'agit pas du tout et en
plus quand on prend trop d'antibiotiques
et des résistances l'hygiène c'est pas
seulement se laver les mains
c'est aussi une centaine de gestes à
connaître mais si on acquiert ses gestes
d'hygiène essentielles non seulement on
évite ce coronavirus mais aussi les
gastro entérites regarder quand il ya la
gastro entérite
en france la moitié du pays surtout
matin alors que des pays comme le japon
ça joue très peu ils ont une très bonne
idée vous appelez-vous par exemple est
ce que les français continuent un
certain nombre de gestes que je pense
peut-être au masque on sait qu'il est
obligatoire dans les transports publics
est ce qu'il faudrait répéter ces
épisodes pour d'autres virus moins grave
que le covin mais un petit peu trop loin
quand c'est une grippe saisonnière
banale comme chaque année franchement ça
passe et bien vaccin pour la grippe
qu'on peut utiliser
par contre il ya des gestes le lavage
des mains qu'est ce que c'est important
à condition de bien savoir se les laver
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
la façon de se dire bonjour aussi quand
les gens une gastro entérite qui serre
la main à tout le monde où ils trippent
ça contamine mais quel est votre
pronostic
c'est pas un diagnostic c'est un
pronostic au médecin que vous êtes
on a tous changer nos comportements et
on s'est vus véritablement changé
pendant deux mois ça reste ces gestes là
on imagine par exemple que le prochain
virus de la grippe vous pensez qu'il
atteindra moins deux personnes liées à
tous ces gestes intégré au quotidien je
pense que ça commence à venir notamment
le lavage des mains ça va rester
maintenant le fait de se serrer la main
s'embrasser c'est pas si simple que ça
de changer ses habitudes pour fait la
bise ou pas non pas du tout vous
regardez dans le quelqu'un deux mois et
demi vous tend la main
pasteur d'ailleurs ne ser ait jamais la
main des gens quand quelqu'un vous tend
la main et vous le laissez votre époque
c'était une autre époque passe mais vous
la personne en face on vous tend la main
vous c'est toujours difficile comme la
situation moi je propose une solution
ce que font les américains ils font un
orgue en fait rien ne se touchent
il se tapotent comme ça chacun tourne
vers l'extérieur
c'est mieux que rien ça donne à côté en
même temps affectif et chaleureux sans
qu'il y ait de contact peau à peau on
est prêt à eux de nous les français on
est des latins on aime ça touche oui
mais je vu beaucoup de pratiques
différentes bon le coude le pied face
chacun essayait de la prenait ce que
différentes donc il ya aussi une
créativité a changé de l'habitude mais
vous souhaitez déjà mises reviennent ou
pas au choc chacun fait un jour qui veut
oui mais messi s'il faut s'en passer
pour éviter de la propagation de
de maladie mais je trouve qu'on peut
trouver autre chose et chaque année
changer de gestes mais sur la question à
laquelle j'ai pas complètement répondu
sur la deuxième phase où la deuxième
vague
je pense la réponse elle est pas l est
pas chez le virus du côté du virus la
réponse là du côté des français et des
pratiques que l'on va conserver ou pas -
on conservera ses pratiques de
protection sanitaire plus elle a de
chances qu'ils aient une deuxième vague
qui reviennent voilà donc
l'apprentissage se fait bien le trouble
relecture des cas gens qui y sont moins
respectueux mais globalement quand même
je pense que les français ont bien
respecté on appris et la réponse et les
collectivités pour moi une des
dimensions je pense du post co vite
comment on peut globalement faire
apparaître beaucoup plus cette capacité
collective à agir et se sent ce commun
en tout cas le sens de l'intérêt général
je pense si on peut arriver à voir que
chaque français chaque comportement de
france elle lit la situation de l'autre
pourraient peut-être déjà bâti aux
sociétés un peu plus consensuel un peu
plus alors on va on va parler
on a parlé de l'hygiène mais peut-être
stefan wul est intervenu ensuite on
parlera des nouvelles méthodes de
consommation de stefan
oui j'entends effectivement on
s'interroge sur est ce que les gestes
qu'on va continuer ou pas à faire nous
protégerons oopad des virus des
bactéries mais il ya d'autres grandes
causes de mortalité on s'est dit qu'on
avait découvert pendant cette épidémie
que rien n'était plus précieux qu'une
vie et qu'il fallait être prêt à tout
pour sauver une vie sauver des vies
quand on voit le nombre de morts par le
tabac en france et 75 mille morts par an
on alerte jusqu'à présent on les avait
plutôt bien toléré certes on a des
politiques mais rien de drastique pour
empêcher ces morts le cancer pareil
c'est la première cause de mortalité et
pourtant on n'a jamais été aussi féroce
dans la lutte contre ni tabac ni corsair
qu'on l'a été contre le coran ne profère
salman à la question de stéphane on en a
beaucoup fait et raison sur sur le co
vide et quelque part est ce que ça ne
montre pas en creux une forme d'
insuffisant sur d'autres maladies
mortelles ya khouya en france à peu près
je crois 650 mille morts par an donc de
différents cancers cardiovasculaires etc
donc quelque part on s'est concentré sur
le co vide il ya tout le reste
quelque part moi ce que j'ai remarqué
c'est que les sujets qui était en
réanimation majoritairement était en
excès de poids pour présenter souvent du
diabète
autrement dit le mode de vie on parle
d'hygiène de se laver les mêmes il ya
l'hygiène de vie qui apparaît très
importante et je découvre avec plaisir
que les français se mettent de plus en
plus à l'activité physique ça à vrai
bouclier
on a même fait une découverte ya pas
longtemps on s'est aperçu que c'était il
ya un mois une équipe américaine a
découvert une enzyme qu'on appelle le
cso des est sécrétée lors de l'exercice
physique et qui est extra un antiviral
puissant autrement dit déjà de se mettre
à faire de l'exercice c'est déjà
extraordinaire parce qu'on baisse de 40%
cancer alzheimer maladies
cardiovasculaires trouvait juste une
demi heure par jour
si en même temps on fait attention à ce
qu'on mange on lutte contre l'excès de
poids
je le répète 30 % de calories en moins
c'est 20% de vie en plus donc quelque
part c'est une prise de conscience pour
l'hygiène de infectieuses aussi
l'hygiène de vie c'est ça c'est notre
immunité notre bouclier si on commence à
s'alimenter différemment de façon plus
saine et donc il ya des leçons à tirer
et des leçons positives à tirer tout
cela on avance sur la question
économique parce qu'elle est centrale le
coc vite d'après on commence à regarder
c'est un peu tôt pour faire des bilans
mais c'est que les consommations les
comportements face à la consommation
changent un peu les ventes de livres
sans vol de vélo également on va dans un
magasin pour choisir ce que l'on fait on
sait ce qu'on veut acheter on perd pas
de temps à flâner on se laisse moins
tentés et plus globalement la
consommation est plutôt timide
est ce que ça vous surprend ça je pense
que c'est difficile de faire des
tendances là maintenant parce que chacun
est et des retards de d'achat à faire il
faut regarder ce type de comportement va
être structurant de la nouvelle
consommation ou c'est juste un effet de
retard
non je pense que de chacun dans son
comportement c'est ce que j'ai observé
mois mais nous en particulier c'est que
après une phase de confinement qui a eu
des ballons temps on ne revient pas tout
de suite à la vie normale on est pas
ressorti tout de suite a progressivement
les gens sont restés chez eux beaucoup
plus longtemps le le soir etc
le moins de dîner chez à midi sur le
terrain on a peur pour notre emploi donc
on va pas se ruer sur une nouvelle
voiture
on craint au contraire des lendemains
qui déchantent donc on épargne on a
beaucoup épargné on a épargné 55
milliards alors que d'habitude et parmi
eux cinq par par mois là on a fait 55
milliards dans mon club continue oui
mais donc c'est la question de la
confiance
je pense que le gouvernement a fait tous
les plans que j'ai vu moi en europe et
dans le monde je pensais le plan le plus
sécurisant qu'on est plus faire ça mais
à 100% en tout cas massivement essayer
de sécuriser les entreprises j'étais
avec le président de la chambre de
commerce du grand est qui dit on a
éteint la lumière
donc on a gardé les outils de travail
les structures sauf quelques entreprises
qui étaient déjà en difficulté pour
lequel le coc vide à accélérer encore
les difficultés mais en gros on a éteint
la lumière maintenant rallume la lumière
doucement sur le fait et on a confiance
et ça va repartir
et bien sûr des gens qui vont aller au
tapis mais mais relativement peu soit
n'y a pas de confiance il n'y a pas de
consommation et la crise qui était une
ruse de 2 3 à 4 mois
mettre une crise structurelle et là les
entreprises vont vous tomber beaucoup
plus massivement donc on a droit deux
trois quatre mois pour relancer la
consommation crée la confiance relative
de la consommation pour que la crise
qu'on vient de vivre puisse être dépassé
on le voit dans le tourisme il y aura
pas mal de touristes en france cette
année ça risque jusqu'à mais simplement
sur l'idée je vous trouve un peu
optimiste et tant mieux on a besoin
d'optimisme mais quand on entend les
chiffres et qu'on n'entend que c'est
minimum - 8 % de pib
sans doute un peu plus ça veut dire que
ça va être une crise terrible on voit
mal comment avec une telle baisse de la
richesse
ça va avoir des conséquences sur le pays
et comment ça va on a vu l'augmentation
du chômage comment cette augmentation va
se résout pas sûr que l'on n'est pas
content les dépôts de bilan bon accès
s'accélérait la rentrée cet optimisme il
s'est plaint le jeune junkie août je
suis pas optimiste je donne la ligne de
crête pour qu'on puisse sortir le moins
mal possible de cette situation si on ne
sort pas de cette façon là et là on va
verser dans une crise massive forte et
de pendant de nombreuses années
puisqu'on aura un élan endetté le pays
et de une absence qui ne sera pas forte
mais il ya une étude qui montre que en
allemagne l'année prochaine liste pour
avoir 10% au troisième vingt donc on y
vient à la comparaison parce que on a
complètement gelé l'activité pendant
pendant deux mois et demi trois mois
mais aujourd'hui on redémarre on perd
toujours par rapport aux mois de l'année
dernière mais on perd de moins en moins
on peut très bien imaginer qu'en juillet
ou en août on faire revenir à un niveau
à peu près 0 voilà c'est bien c'est pas
seulement ce qui se passait là
le coefficient de croissance dans les
modes de l'interview chronofoot parce
que vous inquiéter si je puis dire mais
c'est bien normal sur la chronique de
richard vers les bons soirs il sera bien
sûr mais c'est l'art des transitions
merci au contraire on va s'arrêter un
instant avec vous sur le dé confinement
chez nos voisins européens c'est
d'ailleurs votre chronique donc cette
semaine pour faire repartir l'économie
on le sait beaucoup de pays comme
l'allemagne d'italie d'espagne ce sont
des conflits nés avant nous et les
magasins les usines d administration ont
rouvert dites-nous exactement comment ça
s'est passé ce que ça a marché
on entendait l'exemple positif de
l'allemagne avec vous nos fonctions à
l'instant alors d'abord myriam il faut
savoir que mesurer l'effet du
déconfinement sur le plan économique sur
seulement deux ou trois semaines c'est
quand même très très peu notamment parce
que tous les pays n'ont pas le même
système d'indemnisation la france
pendant ce confinement a été très
généreuse l'amortisseur social français
a extrêmement bien semble-t-il
fonctionné
alors quand on regarde les pays qui nous
entourent il ya un mot qui revient
faisons attention c'est la prudence la
prudence économique et la prudence en
matière de consommation alors prenons
l'italie par exemple vous savez l'italie
a commencé à des confiner le 18 mai ces
commerces et cafés ses restaurants et
bien aujourd'hui le moral des
entrepreneurs italiens n'a jamais été
aussi bas il est au plus bas depuis 2000
191 et le moral des consommateurs dans
un sondage récent
il est au plus bas depuis 2013 2013
c'est d'une date importante à ce moment
là la crise de la dette italienne était
à son sommet alors en allemagne j'avais
moi même vu à sarrebruck le 20 avril les
magasins réouvrir je me souviens d'une
bijouterie où le commerçant attendait
les clients est bien là aussi ça n'a pas
vraiment produit un effet sur la
consommation
d'ailleurs il ya un chiffre important en
allemagne on prévoit 50 mille faillite
de commerce des deux détails c'est donc
un chiffre tout à fait significatif et
c'est peut-être aussi cela qui explique
le revirement d'angela merkel qui comme
vous le savez a proposé un plan de
relance massif à base d'emprunts
européens avec emmanuel macron regardons
maintenant l'espagne alors l'espagne
c'est eux le 4 mai qu'ils ont commencé à
des conflits nés et en espagne il y à
une marque très symbolique c'est la
marque d'habillement zara lé fameux
groupe indie texte est bien une du texte
dès maintenant commencer soldes c'est
pour vous dire que les clients ne sont
pas vraiment revenu dans les magasins il
y est en revanche un indicateur
intéressant c'est que le cours de bourse
de la société est remonté lui en
permanence au mois de mai donc encore
une fois trop tôt pour savoir si des
confiné voici trois semaines était plus
habile sur le plan économique il n'ya
rien d'irréparable pour la france il ya
peut-être même un avantage parce que la
france dé confine au moment où on voit
que le virus a presque disparu
autrement dit c'est le meilleur moment
pour la confiance ben voilà une note
positive merci richard bruno fuchs
quelle est votre réaction
ondées confine à point nommé vous êtes
vous êtes confiant quand on est élu
qu'est ce qu'on dit à ses administrés on
leur dit il faut faire repartir
l'économie n'hésitez pas c'est le moment
d'acheter
d'abord on les écoute parce que jean
chez moi ont besoin de beaucoup parler
dire quand on a vécu deux mois et demi
comme ça de traumatismes quotidien on a
besoin de beaucoup parler alors je les
écoute je parle beaucoup et puis ensuite
on essaie de voir qu'est ce que l'on
pourrait faire aujourd'hui et pas demain
qu'on n'a pas vu qu'on ne faisait pas
avant quelques comment on peut changer
comment peut évoluer mais pas mal de
conversations sont autour de ce sujet là
aujourd'hui que je ne faisais pas avant
comment je vais évoluer par exemple la
pratique du vélo énormément de vélo que
l'on voit pas forcément d'achat mais
pratique du vélo dans la rue est
beaucoup plus de vélos qu'avant donc
j'ai d'ailleurs les vélo un vélo
moi je pense que dans tout sans être
optimiste dans toute crise on a toujours
historiquement réussi à dépasser la
crise est-ce qu'on va le faire en trois
mois est ce qu'on va le faire en deux
ans l'idée c'est effectivement de
trouver les ressources et je plais dans
le haut rhin les gens sont vraiment
combatifs ils ont envie de dépasser
cette crise de tout faire pour faire
repartir leurs économies locales ans
pour terminer ces localisations votre
année le mental pour terminer ce débat
d'un mot le premier projet de loi si
vous aviez l'initiative là dans quelques
semaines dans l'hémicycle pour porter
une réforme qui donnerait du sens
concrètement à ce monde d'après ce
serait quoi et bien moi j'ai écrit une
lettre près de république qui va partir
cette semaine qui est de demander de
relocaliser un certain nombre
d'activités qu'elles précisément en
alsace c'est du textile
et puis principalement bien sûr les
médicaments puisque on a une grande
histoire une expertise une compétence en
terme de santé publique et de
médicaments réduire la dépendance à la
leçon voilà je dis médicaments dans le
rhin qui a beaucoup souffert
ce que l'on sait bien faire voilà il
faut par l'eau prisé pour relocaliser il
faut rajouter là où il ya des expertises
là où il des compétences si nous avons
cette expérience et l'appel n'est pas
passée inaperçue merci beaucoup merci
bruno fou je rappelle le titre de votre
livre frédéric saldmann on est mieux
jamais mieux soit aligné que par soi
même titre ironique s'il en est pour un
médecin
mais il est dit merci beaucoup à partir
à présent aux états unis est le pays
déjà secoué vous le savez par le cos
vite voir ressurgir ses vieux démons
depuis une semaine la colère défaire le
partout qu'elle prenne la forme de
cortège pacifique ou d'émeutes urbaines
la mort insupportables de georges floyd
afro américain de 46 ans insiste fixiez
par un policier blanc à minneapolis la
semaine dernière cette mort ne passe pas
et donald trump n'a rien vu venir
nathalie guillois
[Musique]
des manifestants au pied de l'autel de
trump
la police anti-émeutes présente tout
près de la maison blanche
ça coince pour donald trump confronté à
un climat de tension inédit donald trump
a traîné avant de prendre la parole dans
la foulée des événements de minneapolis
et quand il prend la parole
il s'adresse uniquement à son électorat
nous n'autoriserons pas la gauche
radicale les voyous et autres partout
dans notre pays et dans le monde à
mettre le feu à des communautés
nous ne laisserons pas cela se produire
cela fait mal aux plus démunis à cinq
mois des élections présidentielles sa
réélection sera t-elle une formalité
comme de nombreux analystes le prévoyait
il ya quelques semaines et fait ne vont
pas travailler contre lui parce que en
fait ça fait une petite minorité qui
fait beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de
distractions beaucoup de violence mais
la majorité
pas du tout apprécié c'est fait
la version officielle c'est que dans son
camp on ne s'inquiète pas encore mais
les ennuis commencent à s'accumuler
dangereusement une gestion de crise du
coronavirus calamiteuse une crise
économique d'une ampleur inédite 25
millions d'emplois détruits au mois
d'avril le taux de chômage face de 4,4 à
près de 15 % du jamais vu depuis des
années 1930 mais pour cette journaliste
ni ces chiffres ni l'attitude de donald
trump n'auront un impact sur l'élection
présidentielle et rien n'est joué ça
peut être contre intuitif mais en fait
trump se solidifie avec sa base et
jusqu'à présent sa base n'a pas vraiment
bougé en dépit de tout ce qui s'est
passé
il l'a dit lui-même
vous pourrez tuer quelqu'un en plein
milieu de manhattan de personnes lui
dirai rien sa base s'est solidifiée
autour de lui car rien de nouveau dans
la façon dont montreux à j
il ya vraiment rien de nouveau il a
toujours dit une chose et son contraire
il a menti en soutenant qu'il disait la
vérité en dépit des faits il a agonisé
d'injures ses opposants qui avait raison
il n'y a rien de nouveau là mais la
ligne dure que le président semble avoir
choisi risque de lui faire perdre des
électeurs
les modérés pour l'instant joe biden le
candidat démocrate distance donald trump
de 10 points dans les sondages françois
hollande à exclure merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes député la république en
marche des français d'amérique du nord
et président de la commission des
affaires économiques on a hâte de vous
entendre sur sur ce qu'ils vous disent
justement sur sur ses déchirures qui
s'étale aux états unis partout dans le
pays vous dialoguez ce soir avec
françois durpaire françois bon sens my
home grown il ouvre cette émission et ça
fait plaisir de vous à voir en vrai
historien spécialiste des états unis est
effectivement chroniqueur souvent
derrière son écran mais enchères en est
ce soir je signale tiens je voulais
absolument le faire parce qu'il faut
lire des livres même après le
confinement histoire mondiale du bonheur
c'est l'ouvragé que vous avez co dirigé
que dirige et pardonnez moi et c'est
chez alain non ces chenilles offert ce
midi joly je croyais que c'était albin
michel ménard et labrador aujourd'hui
c'est la vrai frère d'alain corbin qui
est un grand plus à rien et également
alors on va commencer avec une carte
parce que c'est quand même très
impressionnant de voir ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis à plus de 140 villes qui
ont manifesté parfois c'est violent
parfois c'est pacifique
on va la voir cette carte regarder
pratiquement tous les états c'est très
impressionnant ont manifesté avec avec
une trentaine de grandes vide avec la
garde nationale dans une quinzaine
d'états garde nationale faut rappeler un
cc l'armée avec avec fusils mitrailleurs
et blindés françois durpaire ça fait
combien de temps qu'on n'avait pas vu ça
aux états unis alors depuis les émeutes
de los angeles a envoyé jeudi émeutes
alors qu'ils n'avaient pas dire et me
fais partiront
utilise toujours le mot en anglais riots
de mode émeutes or le mode émeutes et en
anglais ça décrédibilise en quelque
sorte la rébellion afro américaine et
depuis toujours et je regardais un peu
la presse des années 60 on utilise
toujours ce mode et métiers et des buts
alors que la rébellion s'est inscrit
dans la démocratie américaine comme un
droit fondamental
d'ailleurs donald trump a appelé à la
rébellion il ya peu de temps contre les
gouverneurs du ministre ou du michigan
la boston tea party qui est à la
naissance du pays c'est une rébellion
sauf que les noirs n'ont pas d'enfants à
une rébellion on leur dit vous êtes des
émeutiers
alors c'est pas pour dire que dans ce
qu'on a vu le talent est là mais souvent
l'histoire médiatique et c'est pas
uniquement aujourd'hui occulte un les
temps pacifiques occulte toutes les fois
où les gens rentrent chez eux après la
mort d'un d'un homme noir et occulte
tout le temps où les gens sont patients
écoute les autorités disent
effectivement on vous fait confiance
mais là pour le coup ça n'a pas
fonctionné ça n'a pas fonctionné pour
une raison aussi simple on a parlé du
coc u19 en a et en ayant encore ça s'est
passé très mal aux états unis à tel
point d'ailleurs que les américains
avaient un éditorial qui disait c'est
peut-être l'année la pire de l'histoire
des états unis parce que c'est un mille
morts car c'est pire que le bilan bilan
humain qu'on a comparé aux attentats
c'est la grande dépression 1929 c'est
aussi la grande dépression et ses 1968
donc vous avez la date des émeutes
raciales vous avez la date de
l'effondrement économique et vous avez
la date d'une guerre c'est aussi deux
fois le gala guerre du vietnam donc
peut-être l'année la pire de l'histoire
moderne des états unis parce que la
guerre de sécession évidemment quand les
états en faillite désunissent évidemment
qui est dans la rue
qu'est-ce qu'on a l'impression que c'est
tout pays catalan non s'il ya des blancs
il ya plus de blancs qu'avant et
exactement c'est pas c'est pas 1968
c'est pas 1992
on n'est pas dans la on pourrait penser
que c'est exactement la même amérique
oui ils se battent pour la même chose
c'est que c'est évidemment le racisme et
ça faut pas dire que c'est par là c'est
vraiment raciste toutes les pancartes
ces noms à jim crow non à l'esclavagé
etc
mais regardez ces images vous avez une
amérique multiculturelle
c'est le paradoxe c'est l'amérique
d'aujourd'hui qui manifestent contre
l'amérique d'hier et je vous donne juste
un symbole la fille de dee blasio le
maire de new york lui il est italo
américain
sa femme est africaine américaine et
donc sa fille et métis lui dit rentrez
chez vous etc
mais elle elle a été arrêtée par la
police week-end toute fille de mr
qu'elle est de new york
et avec son afro apporte son afro
o'farrell et caetera et c'est cette
amérique là deuxième exemple parfait de
nombreux feux l'avant il sort et elle a
fêté la tribune d'un monsieur blanc un
papa blanc qui dit j'ai peur pour mon
fils son fils est métisse sa femme parce
que en 1968 les mariages entre noirs et
blancs venaient juste d'être légalisé
aujourd'hui un mariage sur cinq est
entre personnes de communautés
différentes
donc on a l'impression que c'est la
neige d'hier mais non la bière
d'aujourd'hui elle est là elle vous
voyez sur les images roland lescure vous
la comprenez cette colère vous seriez
aux états unis vous seriez dans la rue
oui alors il faut reconnaître que depuis
1968 depuis 1992 la dernière grande date
des émeutes suite à là encore à la mort
d'anwar tabassé par des brevets king
l'amérique a beaucoup progressé mais
l'amérique reste extrêmement clivé donc
on a effectivement plus de métissage on
a plus de présence des afro-américains
dans le milieu économique dans le milieu
médiatique on a quand même élu un
président noir est réélu un président
noir
ce qui n'a pas empêché les inégalités de
ne pas se réduire à mano s'accroître un
peu pendant ses deux mandats et votre
carte elle est intéressante parce que
finalement c'est toute l'amérique qui
manifestent parce que les mille et
quelques morts dans les deux tiers sont
des afro-américains qui tombent sous les
balles de la police tous les ans ils
sont aussi dans tous les états
américains
donc on a une amélioration de la
situation en apparence mais là bas on le
mesure on sait que la discrimination est
encore frais fait social est avant tout
sociale ont parlé tout à l'heure de la
crise économique
c'est plus de 35 millions de chômeurs en
quelques semaines donc plus qu'en 1929
en quelques années et c'est des victimes
de cette de cette chute sociale
absolument exceptionnelles sont beaucoup
à chercher dans la communauté avril
montrait d'ailleurs on voulait en parler
plus tard mais mais c'est pas grave
parce que c'est vrai que les inégalités
raciales elles sont toujours là à vendre
ai parlé de la réponse de trump des
afro-américains 2,4 fois plus de chances
de mourir du coronavirus et le bureau du
recensement des états-unis qui nous
l'apprend ils sont aussi plus nombreux
en prison l'accès à la santé est
difficile également
et puis et puis des chiffres de la
pauvreté également 20 8% des afro
américains vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté contre 17,6 pour cent des
hispaniques et 10 pour pour les blancs
si rien ne change c'est le rêve
américain ça s'appelle alors vous savez
malcom x 10 est le rêve américain pour
nous les noirs c'est le cauchemar
américain
le cauchemar américain pour les
habitants de minnesota prenons pas les
sondages nationaux puisque ça a éclaté
dans le minnesota dans le minnesota donc
à minneapolis est très simple vous donne
trois chiffres
la première c'est que les noirs c'est 20
% de la population de minneapolis ses
64% des personnes qui est qui sont à
terre suite à une intervention de la
police mais intervention violente comme
on a vu avec floyd de deuxième soit 47
mille dollars 47 mille dollars d'écarts
entre les ménages noirs et blancs annuel
à minneapolis est troisième c'est le
coronavirus 6% de l'état du minnesota
pour le pour des gens atteints du corona
virus mais c'est 30% pour les noirs et
face à cela donald trump qui n'a rien vu
venir
il était quasi réélu dans un fauteuil de
président américain en pleine campagne
il n'a pas compris ce qui se passait il
était en campagne électorale depuis
trois ans et demi depuis qu'il a été élu
et pendant trois ans et trois mois il a
fait la campagne sur une chose
l'économie on a la meilleure économie du
monde et depuis toujours et là en trois
mois on rentre dans une récession
historique
il faut qu'ils changent à 180° son axe
de campagne et ça j'ai peut-être l'air
un peu cynique mais malheureusement je
pense qu'il l'est ça lui donne une
occasion en or pour axé sa campagne sur
deux mots law and order la justice et
l'ordre et je pense qu'il va faire une
campagne extrêmement sécuritaire mais
derrière ces cas là on pense à nixon où
on passe à celui qui avait échoué en
pension
l'ordre alors qu'il y avait des émeutes
c'est un diviseur qu'est ce que c'est
réconcilier la choisit ce camp là il
choisit la mention je suis convaincu que
dans ces moments là partout dans le
monde on a besoin d'unité et le vrai
leadership ça va être de promouvoir
l'unité est en général un président des
états unis se fait réélire plutôt sur un
discours assez consensuel et
conciliateurs exactement il a été élu
sur un clivage très fort et finalement
ils renforcent dans son élection et ça
marche au sens où sa base électorale
reste plus convaincu que jamais on sait
bien qu'il ya un besoin de sécurité
suite à cette crise sanitaire parce que
les états dans le monde entier ont tous
un peu échoué à préserver la santé des
habitants
et donc il va renforcer sa base
électorale il sait qu'il a un candidat
face à lui qui est pas très fort et donc
idée maiden il joe biden il est en très
large est tellement oui alors joe biden
est quand même à dix points au dessus de
donald trump aujourd'hui donc un écart
beaucoup plus important que celui qui
séparait hillary clinton et d'un train
bilan position de conflit peut jouer
utilisateurs les faire de la question
raciale la halle centrale de la campagne
exactement donald trump en fait il a
c'est très simple il va jouer
d'abord il a été tétanisée ans l'a pas
entendu parler le le mot du week-end
c'était ou et donald trump parce qu'ils
avaient des conseillers qui lui disait
un peu tout et son contraire notamment
qu'il disait attention vote
afro-américains qui est pas une
mobilisation du côté de bayonne de
sarria pro américain mais il ya quand
même là il ya une image aujourd'hui qui
montre qu'il est sorti de la maison
blanche et avec son mot d'ordre
je suis le candidat de l'or d'ailleurs
c'est exactement son ce qu'il a fait en
2016 je suis le candidat de l'ordre sauf
qu'il ya une différence à être nixon
nixon en 1968 il était vierge
il était vierge il a été vice président
mais il n'était pas c'était pas le
président sauf que là lui il apparaît
pas comme le candidat de l'ordre il a
fait en 2016 leila comme le président du
désordre et il peut apparaître en tout
cas comme le président du désordre
puisque
en tout cas pour l'instant elle a tout à
fait raison c'est à dire que il ya les
indépendants les démocrates foutront by
donne et le républicain votre
contraintes dont quelques indépendants
qui vont faire la différence
aujourd'hui les républicains ils sont
plus inquiétés par les émeutes
qu'inquiéter par le racisme les
démocrates ils sont plus inquiétés par
l'image de racistes par les émeutes et
les indépendants ils sont aussi offusqué
par les émeutes que par le racisme
si joe biden arrive à tenir ce discours
d' équilibre ce qu'avait fait vous voir
rappeler le discours de philadelphie de
obama en 2007 s'il arrive à le faire en
2008 pardon eh bien j'ai une question un
peu direct
donald trump est il raciste non alors
attendez je charlotte si oui on se
souvient des dépositions sur les super
mais on ne juge pas un président il a
dans la thèse qui disait à ce qui s'est
passé sur la base de ce dont il s'est
entouré il quand on regarde son
track-record comme on dit aux états unis
en termes nos conseillers on peut pas
dire qu'il s'entoure de gens dont la
tolérance face à la diversité soit la
qualité première steve madden évidemment
qui a fait sa campagne en 2016 et
d'autre depuis
juste pardon pourrait aussi quelque
chose de très intéressant sur lequel je
pense qu'il faut quand même insisté
c'est que donald trump a en grande
partie été élu en 2016 parce que les
afro américains ne sont pas allés voter
donc là le risque auquel il fait face
c'est qu'il est démocrate il puisse
remobiliser les afro-américains ce que
va sans doute faire du hubei donne pour
aller voter démocrate et ça ça va être
quand même un des enjeux marginaux de
cette élection jeux d'amour pour
terminer à super je voudrais vous
ramener à la france parce qu'il ya aussi
des questions sur leur plaisir
moi je voulais vous parler de monsieur
important aujourd'hui que ça me tient à
coeur d'en parler c'est l'ancien maire
du mini aux polices l'ancien maire 2001
police appelle rt ryback et il a dit
aujourd'hui je mets jeu c'est manon mea
culpa mon mea culpa
voilà voilà ce que j'aurais dû faire
j'aurais dû démilitariser la police
j'aurais dû renforcer la police
de proximité j'aurais dû forme et mieux
les policiers mais tout ça ne sert à
rien et ne servira à rien pourquoi tant
qu en fait les américains blancs il est
blanc faut que le précise les américains
blancs nous n'aurons pas compris qu'il
fallait changer la culture de la peur et
pourquoi les noirs américains sont en
insécurité sont en danger aux états unis
parce que les blancs pensent que les
noirs sont un danger
c'est ça le cercle vicieux mortifère est
il terminé sur cette phrase lac est
incroyable posons nous la question
américain de savoir pourquoi les noirs
non armés sont abattus par la police au
moment où les blancs armée ne sont qu'
arrêter vous voulez avoir le mot de la
fin roland lescure
jusqu'où ira l'incendié à votre avis
qu'est ce qu'on regarde là je pense
qu'il ya quand même ça va s'arrêter
discours de soi-même pèse maintenant
mais il ya des discours d'apaisement qui
ont été portés on a vu le frère de
george clooney
hier appelé à l'apaisement on a vu
barack obama a aussi sorti en disant
l'activisme c'est bien la violence c'est
pas bien aller voter allez voter pour
les présidentielles et surtout en fait
aller voter pour les élections des
gouverneurs et des mères qui in fine et
son saut qui dirige la police et le vrai
défi vous l'avez dit c'est que la police
américaine aujourd'hui très diverses
dans le pays
il ya des lieux où elle est encore
extrêmement dublanche insuffisamment
diverses et mal formées ça ça va être un
défi et en france aussi la question des
violences policières
elle se pose c'est un dossier brûlant
vous le savez monsieur le député à peine
déposée il ya une proposition de loi
signée eric ciotti qui fait déjà couler
beaucoup d'encre elle propose de flouter
les visages des policiers filmés par des
journalistes ou par des quidams dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions et ses
vidéos servent souvent de pièces à
conviction lors de passages à l'acte
mais elles nuisent aussi ses vidéos aux
forces de l'ordre et à leur entourage
comme nous l'expliquent thomas des prêts
dans ma journée à l'assemblée où
exactement meriam on a tous vu ces
images de georges floyd à terre et tout
fait par un policier américain
parfaitement reconnaissable et bien ces
vidéos elles ne seront peut-être plus
possible en france dans quelques temps
c'est en tout cas ce que souhaitent
certains députés les républicains qui
ont déposé une proposition de loi
je vais vous raconter jingle
[Musique]
alors cette proposition de loi elle a
été déposé par plusieurs députés les
républicains eric ciotti en tête elle
vise à rendre non identifiables les
forces de l'ordre lors de la diffusion
d'image dans l'espace médiatique
bref à flouter les policiers sous peine
d'une amende de 15000 euros et d'un an
d'emprisonnement
mais dans le contexte ça tombe plutôt
mal alors avec stéphanie des pierres on
a voulu demander à celui qui en était à
l'origine ce qu'il en pensait eric
ciotti j'ai travaillé cette proposition
de loi il ya plusieurs semaines elle a
été cosigné par mes collègues ya
plusieurs semaines donc elle n'a aucun
lien avec l'actualité
l'objectif est d'éviter etc je suis en
cela une demande forte des policiers il
souhaite que la vie privée des policiers
soient protégés
les avis divergent sur ce texte il ya
ceux qui s'en félicite comme le syndicat
alliance police qui applaudit le fait
qu'une de ces propositions soient
reprises par des parlementaires et puis
il ya ceux qui craignent pour les
libertés fondamentales la liberté de la
presse pour david dufresne journaliste
spécialiste des violences policières
et puis appareils pour eric coquerel il
est même en train d'écrire une tribune
bonjour les coquerelles pour vous cette
proposition de loi les républicains
elle ne passe par tenons à le passeport
parce qu elle consisterait en réalité à
nier encore plus les violences
policières les discriminations du fait
de la police il sait pas supportable on
a déjà beaucoup de mal à faire admettre
au gouvernement que c'est pas juste des
bavures individuelles qui a un problème
dans la police de racisme de
discrimination
à force de nier ça devient de plus en
plus systémique et ça donne la part
belle à ceux qui les pratiquent aux
dépens de ceux qui du coup en viennent à
se taire parce que il voit que les
choses peuvent se faire en impunité je
parle dans la police les républicains
disent que c'est pour protéger la vie
privée et la famille des policiers pour
protéger la vie plus des policiers si la
police et exemple il y aura pas besoin
de les filmer
pourquoi les gens ont été filmés ou d'un
moment c'est qu'il ya des pratiques qui
sont faites et que les films et est
d'abord un acte préventif je te filme
donc est obligé de respecter la loi et
souvent c'est ça qui marche le texte il
devrait être débattue dans les
prochaines semaines en commission des
lois mais compense les députés de la
majorité
on leur a posé la question bonjour
coralie dubost bonjour cette proposition
les républicains c'est une bonne chose
je pense que c'est surtout une fausse
bonne idée parce qu'en réalité elle est
trop général n'est pas précise
c'est un coup de com je pense il est
vrai qu'il faut que nous réfléchissions
à comment protéger les familles des
fonctionnaires pas de cette façon parce
que de cette façon ce serait une une
coupure totale avec la possibilité de
capter des images sur une scène dans la
rue avec un fonctionnaire de police or
nous avons malheureusement pu constater
même si ça reste très marginal que
parfois ça pouvait être nécessaire voilà
myriam nul doute que le sujet fera
beaucoup débat dans les prochaines
semaines même s'il a très peu de chances
d'être adoptée mais on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler dans ma journée à
l'assemblée
renescure une réaction à ce texte cioni
coquerel de sceller caricature de ce
qu'il faut pas faire aujourd'hui on a
besoin d'unité et pas de division l'un
et l'autre sont en train de diviser la
france
merci merci d'avoir été caustique merci
à tous les deux terminé comme tous les
soirs avec le jour d'après nouvel
épisode de notre collection d'entretien
consacré ce soir à la crise économique l
ampleur et quelle reprise possible à
l'heure où l'on apprend aujourd'hui que
la récession passe de 8 à 11% du pib
cette année c'est la chef économiste de
l'oscd laurence boone qui répond à nos
questions regarder
[Musique]
on est où là dans mon salon
j'aime unique et la présentation des
perspectives économiques en mars de mon
salon parce que j'étais au 40ème comme
je venais de milan bonjour laurence
boone
oui j'en ai rien vous êtes là chef
économiste de l'oscd eux c'est cet
organisme qui conseille les dirigeants
des des pays développés pendant cette
crise sans précédent va en parler bien
sûr c'est aussi cet organisme qui a mis
en oeuvre le plan marshall après guerre
alors on va parler de cette crise le
coup porté à l'économie par ce virus
il est absolument colossal 8% de
récession rien que pour la france et les
experts disent que ça sera sans doute
beaucoup plus est-ce qu'on peut
maintenant mesurer l'ampleur de cette
crise est ce qu'on peut dire jusqu'où
l'économie va s'effondrer
est-ce qu'on peut mesurer aujourd'hui
est à peu près en temps réel bien qu
imparfaitement c'est le choc sur
l'activité économique qu impose le
confinement et donc sur la production et
sur la consommation
il est très important donc on a deux
moyens de faire ça le premier c'est de
regarder secteur par secteur de
production ce qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas et quand on regarde sa boîte
c'est un choc quand même très très
important puisque il met à l'arrêt en
fait à peu près un quart de l'activité
économique de notre pays
on peut aussi regarder ça du côté de la
consommation ou même moi aujourd'hui on
peut pas acheter tout ce qu'on n'achète
normalement c'est très bien et quand on
regarde de ce côté là c'est + 35 % de
notre consommation qui en fait affectés
concrètement ça veut dire que des
milliers même des centaines de milliers
de personnes vont se retrouver au
chômage c'est ça alors il ya quelque
chose qui est très frappant elle dans
cette crise est qui et qui est
encourageant c'est que la plupart des
pays ont mis en place tout un système de
soutien à l'emploi aux personnes et aux
entreprises pour faire que ce choc qui
qu'on espère temporaire en fait on
puisse de traverser sans trop de pertes
de revenus pour les ménages
et puis en en essayant de s'arranger
pour que les entreprises n'est pas tout
même de trésorerie de cash flow pendant
cette période de confinement donc si on
reste dans un choc limité avec deux mois
et 82 progressivement reprendre une
activité normale
je ne dis pas qu'on va revenir au même
niveau d'emploi exactement je n'oublie
pas que certaines entreprises ne vont
pas avoir des difficultés peut-être même
faillite mais au moins on aura amorti le
choc beaucoup
évidemment s'il ya de plus longtemps et
dans certains secteurs comme le tourisme
navigation la restauration ça va être un
peu plus compliqué donc pour bien
comprendre les mesures de soutien à la
fois aux entreprises et aux salariés des
différents gouvernements et la france en
particulier peuvent permettre
d'augmenter les chances à toutes ces
personnes de garder leur emploi et à
toutes ces entreprises au fond de
reconnecter avec une activité à peu près
normale après la crise absolument
si on prend le secteur de la
construction par exemple non il n'y a
pas de raison qu après la crise avec les
commandes de construction qui sont en
général très longue guerre s'arrête et
comme les employés auront été au chômage
partiel donc ça veut dire toujours dans
l'entreprise et que celles ci ont pour
eux ont pu bénéficier de reports de
taxes de charges de crédit bancaire de
garanties de l'état
en théorie elles sont capables de voir
démarrer à des dès le 12 mai et non en
pratique quand même on va pas redémarré
exactement de la même façon
comme vous savez on va devoir mettre en
place et dans les entreprises parfois ça
va être compliqué des règles de
distanciation social de 10 viennent donc
ça ça veut dire des équipes peut-être
moins grande
ça veut dire un problème pour la cantine
de l'entreprise ça veut dire des
questions sur aller le transport en
commun
donc il ya quand même des chances qu'on
reparte à enlever comme on dit souvent
mais plutôt ont eu très progressivement
alors parlez nous de cette reprise vous
nous dites un u
ça veut dire que en gros après le
déconfinement l'économie va pas repartir
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
les comportements à l'est des
consommateurs pour commencer on va pas
se remettre à consommer à gogo après non
je pense que vous lui avez raison en
fait il ya deux il ya toujours ya deux
effet on peut observer pour la
consommation le premier c'est tout ne va
pas rouvrir dans les mêmes conditions
qu'avant
vous avez par exemple qu'il est petit
magasin de votre quartier
toutes les règles de distanciation
social ça va être gelé des sujets et
puis tant qu'on n'aura pas trouvé de
traitement ou de bac 5 vous et moi on
aura peut-être moins oui de prendre un
métro bondé traverser paris allait
trouver la petite bougie oublier
certains disent que la consommation ne
pourra reprendre qu'à noël et qu'il faut
qu'un choc comme noël pour que les gens
au fond ait envie de consommer à nouveau
et que d'ici là le traumatisme de la
crise et du virus va affecter nos
comportements alors on avance aussi à
deux il ya des choses effectivement
l'anxiété qu'on peut avoir
on est riespach on ne connaît pas très
bien va inciter les personnes d'être
resté plus chez elle clairement à
prendre un avion pour partir en vacances
à être un peu plus compliqué et et si on
pense qu'on va pas revenir à une
situation à peu près normale avec un
traitement avant 2021 mais oui il ya des
chances que la consommation soit valable
et les prix alors qu'est ce qui va se
passer sur le pré les prix quand ya plus
d'offres et qui a plus de demande les
prix comment il repartit s'effondre with
augmente alors les prix c'est peut-être
une des questions les plus difficiles à
appréhender et je pense que on peut la
regarder de façon la première c'est si
vous regardez en global en fait avec
toutes les mesures de l'état on a à peu
près tenu les capacités de production il
n'y a pas trop de pertes on va on va
supposer ni en entreprise ni en emploi
est en revanche on a une consommation
qui est moins élevé qu'avant mais si on
a moins de consommation et autant de
production il ya va y avoir un effet à
la baisse sur les prix mais dans
certains secteurs par exemple
l'agriculture 6
on voit qu'il ya des tensions parce que
il faut des travailleurs saisonniers
pour venir récolter les fruits les
légumes que ces travailleurs saisonniers
c'est difficile de les faire venir tant
qu'on a des restrictions sur les voyages
voilà les prix peuvent effectivement
augmenté quels sont les grands secteurs
les plus pénalisées quels sont les
secteurs gagnants
alors il est comment secteurs les plus
pénalisés c'est tout ce qu'ils vont être
affectés par des mesures de confinement
persistante et bien sûr le voyage alors
l'europe l'europe va intervenir aussi
pour relancer l'économie une fois que
l'économie va repartir une fois qu'on va
ressortir de ce confinement
on se souvient des grands travaux de
roosevelt juste après la crise de 1929
donc quoi il faudrait investir
massivement pour relancer et surtout
dessiné l'économie d'après alors ces
essais c'est toujours la question est là
la plus difficile mais je pense qu'il ya
quand même trois secteurs qui sont très
intéressants à l'appoint pour
accompagner voire accélérer la reprise
et pour dessiner comme vous évite les
contours du monde de demain le premier
c'est le numérique le numérique peut
être le lien entre tous est un
accélérateur de beaucoup de choses donc
on peut penser à équipées en numérique
tous les territoires ruraux pour
s'assurer que les personnes ont accès à
l'éducation à la santé aussi avec l'été
ou consultation pour permettre aux
entreprises de le dead plus intelligente
pour avoir des outils de prévention
santé aussi plus malin avec
l'intelligence artificielle et surtout
surtout pour faire des grilles de
distribution d'énergie qui optimise
entre la production et la consommation
et ça c'est clé pour le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables
et ça c'est mon deuxième point je pense
le deuxième champ très intéressant c'est
s'assurer qu'avec cette crise quand on
va investir dans des infrastructures ça
va être des infrastructures vertes et
respectueuse de l'environnement
et puis le dernier point c'est la santé
vous pouvez nous dessiner comme ça
concrètement en quelques mots cette
économie et ce monde de demain dit s'ils
allaient de 5 10 ans on produira plus
près on mangera mieux
et on bougera - on se déplacera - c'est
ça l'idée je suis pas sûr il ya quelque
chose qui est important dans ce que vous
disais je pense que plus on va rester
dans une période de confinement va être
important la pandémie va être toujours
quelque part dans le décor donc on fait
tampon maintenant plus la période pour
avoir un traitement avec sa longue plus
à la modifier nos comportements c'est
sûr parce que c'est votre corps le bien
c'est la mémoire et ça ça nous impacte
forcément
en revanche si on arrive à être un
traitement je pense qu'on va repartir
assez vite et l'endettement sur qui va
peser cet endettement colossal des états
on est à 115% du pib en france sur les
générations futures et à toi un moyen en
fait de gérer cet endettement le premier
c'est augmenter les impôts mais ces
dépenses ensuite il ya l'inflation
on en parlait tout à l'heure à court
terme on n'en voit pas beaucoup mais à
moyen terme si on vous a baissé les
capacités de production à y parvenir
la dernière chose et je pense qu'il faut
être assez transparent et clair là
dessus c'est une partie de ses dettes va
rester sur le bilan des banques
centrales
et c'est aussi comme ça que tu pour ça
qu'avez vous appris de la gestion de
cette crise qui va nous servir qui devra
nous servir pour après alors que la
chose la plus importante est de choses
pour moi qui sont extrêmement
importantes la première c'est la façon
dont on regarde les risques
c'est très très important de les
intégrer beaucoup plus dans notre
quotidien parce que on en aura d'autres
y aura d'autres accidents y aura des
accidents climatiques y aura d'autres
accidents de santé
et puis la deuxième chose at on appris
ce mois-ci que rien de cours prend place
de contact humain vous à la numérique
mais franchement l'aspect social et est
d'ailleurs les négociations parce que
toujours et posters fait des grandes
réunions
c'est hyper merci infiniment merci
laurence boone d'avoir accepté cet
entretien à distance et à bientôt
j'espère en face à face en chair et en
os une petit beaucoup mis à niveau
numérique
[Musique]
et ainsi s'achève cette émission merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
demain
bien évidemment pour un nouveau ça vous
regarde en direct a demandé s'il a passé
une excellente soirée documentaire avec
l'observation sur elle s'était bien sûr
[Musique]